في السوق هذا المزدحم بالباعه تتقاسم ام
جنات مع الرجال مشقه العمل ومن اجل ان
تحصل على عشرين دولار لسد رمق الاطفال
يتوجب عليها يوميا بيع اكثر من 70 قرصا من
الخبز المعروف بالقدم كفاح مع لقمه العيش
تقول الفتى لا يسمح لها بمغادره المكان
قبل ان تفرغ الكميه التي في حوزتها
مصير فراق قاس اذا القى بثقه على
وحشرها مع اطفالها الثلاثه في غرفه ضيقه
بدت مسكنهم الوحيد بعد ان هجرهم المعيل
فلا شيء يصحبهم في حجرتهم هذه سوى فقر
اثقل كاهلهم منذ اعوام كبقيه اسر في
المدينه كانها قبر قبر عن اياك يعني هي
عباره عن
بنفس الوقت حتى لما اقوم اصلي ما فيش نفس
حتى للسكاده والله انني اصلي ولمن يرقوا
العيال والله العظيم اننا اصلي لبن ياثر
علينا كان احنا من اول الحرب يا ابني نطلب
الله بالحاصل واكلنا وشربنا ما كنش الغلا
ذا لا غير حتى الحرب الغلا واحنا نخرج
علياء مرهق جدا البحث عن القوت اليومي في
المدينه المحاصره هذه فعلى ارصفه الشوارع
تصف عشرات النسوه بحثا عما يسد الرماق
خصوصا من فقدنا ازواجهن في الحرب
مع ثلاثه
من عشرين مليون شخص في اليمن اي ما يعادل
70% من اجمال السكان بحاجه ماسه للمساعده
الانسانيه كم يصعب اذا على ساكن هذه
المدينه الحصول على لقمه العيش في ظل
الحرب والحصار الحوتي فالاسواق هذه تكتظ
بالعديد من الباعه جميعهم يعيشون الضنك
الحياه خصوصا النساء والاطفال الذين
اجبروا على الانخراط في سوق العمل لاعاده
اسرهم هل سعيد العربيه تعز